hello and welcome to gamespot's coverage
of play for all
our summer event where we cover all the
latest and greatest in games
i am kicking off this segment with some
great folks
over from blizzard covering hearthstone
i got dave kosak principal narrative
designer
and conor coo game designer and i'm
michael hyam
i'm here with gamespot and i'm going to
be giving them some questions about
hearthstone
but the first question i want to ask is
how are y'all doing
we're doing great we are doing great the
hearthstone team has been working from
home
uh as as you can imagine still uh
managed to launch the ashes of outland
uh expansion uh from home and now we are
about to bust out with a huge bundle of
content uh for all of our players
the fel fire festival oh i'm doing great
i mean we're super excited for the fel
fire festival and
uh we're excited to bring some new stuff
to battlegrounds and
all over the game really can you give uh
folks a brief overview or a refresher
on exactly what fell firefest means for
hearthstone yeah yeah well the fel fire
festival is kind of an annual holiday
and this year we've gone bigger than
ever because we're taking the fel fire
festival to outland for the ashes of
outland expansion
and there's a there's a whole set of
huge things going on that we spread it
over four weeks
so uh uh we are adding a a new
minion type to battlegrounds we're
adding pirates to the battlegrounds
and and connor will tell you all about
that then we have a huge bundle of
single-player content as well solo
adventures
uh we're introducing a a new demon
hunter hero for players
uh arana starseeker is her name and we
have a whole single-player campaign a
whole
free solo adventure for players to play
uh where you get to meet arana
and uh play through her uh 17 missions
uh as she uh explores outland and
becomes a demon hunter and meets illidan
and uh and craziness ensues
uh our big arch villain of of this
expansion is
mechagear axis uh the failed dr boom
experiment
he's rebuilding uh the the burning
legion into the rusted legion a sort of
half-mechanized half-demonic army that's
been
crashing throughoutland so uh
single-player adventure we'll get to
kind of explore
explore that character and see if we can
take it down uh and then uh
then it continues it continues we're
only halfway through
the fel fire festival at this point uh
because then we have uh
uh challenge modes uh uh it's another
solo adventure this is kind of like uh
it's like outland's greatest hits it's
single-player fights against some of the
greatest
villains uh from the uh burning crusade
era of world of warcraft so you can
fight against
kael'thas and lady bash and all the all
the great villains
from that expansion uh and then we have
a couple great tavern brawls
uh including uh there's a tavern brawl
as a personal favorite of mine it's
called the burn down
where uh we randomly generate decks for
players
and you play against other players and
uh if you lose
you get to keep the deck that beat you
uh for the
for the brawl and use that in the brawl
against other players
and so uh decks kind of spread out and
and we see which one is
is the best yeah there's 17 new minions
uh a bunch of new
uh pirates and we're also gonna be
introducing uh
a new system to battlegrounds uh we're
we're going up to six minion types of
battlegrounds and
uh we wanted to make sure that that
wasn't gonna sort of dilute the minion
pool too much so
at the beginning of every game now we're
going to select randomly
five million types to include in the
game and for the first month
after the patch launch we're gonna have
um pirates in every single game so you
get to play with all those new
minions so i have a lot of in-depth
questions when it comes to
new stuff that's uh coming to
hearthstone and the fel fire festival in
particular so
i need to give a special shout out to
steve watts our game spot editor who
put a lot of these questions together so
first off uh we want to ask uh trial by
uh the trial by fell fire solo
adventures releasing
all five chapters simultaneously unlike
previous adventures which uh rolled out
weekly
uh why did you make this change uh this
time around and um
yeah what was kind of the the thought
process behind changing the way you're
rolling these out
uh there were a couple couple different
things going on one is that we had the
whole fell fire festival going on so we
didn't uh we we had
all kinds of events uh so we didn't want
the single player to
to spread out too far uh the other thing
is uh the single player content this
time around it doesn't uh
introduce new cards into the meta so uh
often uh when we're introducing new
cards we kind of slowly
uh dribble them in over the course of a
few weeks this time we weren't doing
that it's really just about the story
and we kind of wanted people to get the
whole story at once um
uh this is a new character that we're
introducing to hearthstone and her
adventure is really fun when you can
play it through
beginning to end we uh we're giving the
adventure wave for free
uh and we think if people like if they
if you really enjoy playing with the new
hero you really like the new
new hero uh there's an arana star seeker
bundle that you can get
uh it's a 20 20 card packs and you get
the
arana star seeker uh hero skin for your
your demon hunter
uh i know uh you guys mentioned
introducing pirates and
battlegrounds what makes this tribe
different from others like dragons and
mechs
we all know that pirates they really
love one thing they love gold
so one of the little sub
uh strategies of pirates is that they
they play with gold a little bit
so they have a minion that sells for
three gold instead of one
uh that's our free dealing gambler uh
and then
we've got uh pirate captain hagar
uh he gives you a gold whenever you buy
a pirate so they have a little bit of
uh ways of playing with gold um we even
have a minion that
at the end of your turn he gets plus two
plus two for every gold mining you
control
uh his name is gold grubber so that's
one
area of battlegrounds that they're sort
of expanding
pirates are really aggressive they like
attacking so we've got a bunch of
new pirates that have attack triggers
or get benefits from attacking or they
attack immediately
so we have a new tier 6 minion which is
dread captain eliza
and whenever she has whenever a friendly
pirate attacks
she gives all your minions plus one plus
one
and then you have minions like scallywag
at tier one that have death rattle
summoned to one
pirate it attacks immediately so we're
sort of revisiting
uh attack immediately which was a
mechanic we introduced into
battlegrounds
uh with the launch of ashes of outland
actually with
uh illidan's hero power um so we're
using it for pirates here and
they get a lot of really interesting
ways of sort of uh
getting to attack first and uh
benefiting from it
another big change that came with ash's
outland was the addition of demon hunter
how have you felt overall about the meta
following the first
new hero edition uh into the game we're
pretty pleased with how things are
shaping out i mean definitely the goal
from the outset we wanted demon hunter
to be you know
viable and competitive uh right out of
the gate
it did require some balance patching
immediately because it was
it was the first week i don't know if
you had a chance to play it was
demon hunter was incredibly powerful so
there was a
there was a bit of a bit of nudging
early on to uh
kind of adjust the the power level there
um and then
uh but we've been watching it closely
and there's a a pretty diverse meta
going on right now there's some uh
uh there's some decks i actually made
some notes uh uh demon hunter's still
really strong
um there's a couple warrior decks that
are that are doing really well right now
there's a good aggro warrior deck
there's a bomb warrior deck that's been
doing well
no duplicates hunter is really fun to
play that's that's doing well as well
in the meta and a lot of players are
playing rogue so we're seeing a lot of
good variety right now uh and we're
at the halfway point of uh the ashes of
outland cycle
it's it's looking pretty good right now
the there's they're on deck they'll make
some
some adjustments as as necessary but
we're pretty happy with how it's shaking
out right now
so when you go into launching a hero do
you know that you're going to have to
take a very hands-on approach to
the balance or like what goes into the
balancing process beforehand so like
when you introduce
uh new elements like this in the game do
you uh
yeah can you give a little bit more uh
insight on how those things are pulled
off
it's an interesting challenge for the
card design team there so they i mean we
have like
uh years of experience with the other
nine classes we kind of know how they
how they play out
with demon hunter we did not have the
years of experience it was also a
a smaller deck size to be working or a
smaller card set size to be working with
out of the gate a it had to be super fun
to play uh
and uh and b uh wanted to be uh
viable and competitive and and powerful
um
so uh you know you when when you do this
you wanna air maybe on the side of it
being a little stronger than maybe you'd
want so that you can be ready
to to pull it back if you need to uh and
i think even even with that in mind it
was a little stronger than we
thought coming in uh but that's okay
that's okay that they were ready to do
some
some tinkering right away and i think
it's it's at a good level right now
kind of going back to fel fire festival
as a whole this is like a big
uh big four week push with a lot of
different stuff going on
uh in relation to expansions because
like hearthstone's been out since 2014
and there's been i think a pace of three
expansions every year
which is obviously a lot of work to
upkeep a game
so um and also like including something
like
like battlegrounds and building that and
incorporating that into the core part of
the game
when it comes to like fell fire festival
and an event like this
uh how much time and effort goes into
that in relation to
kind of the the the normal things that
you the
normal things that you do to keep
hearthstone going
uh it's kind of uh it's kind of a relay
race so there's different parts of the
design team that all focus on on
different parts of the game
um so certainly we have a whole events
team
that works on our things like the tavern
brawls the holiday events
and it's kind of kind of anchoring this
uh this event
um uh as well as uh and part of that is
the missions team that works on the uh
the the solo content so the the solo
adventures we've been working on
obviously for
for months uh uh right up until the wire
as it as it turned out i think the
gaming industry as a whole has evolved a
lot
in terms of the emphasis on live service
games
and it's been yeah it's been huge and
obviously like blizzard has been on top
of that for a very long time
but has the shift in industry changed
things for a hearthstone team
since its inception
that's uh that's an excellent question
um
you know honestly as a as a designer
you're always sort of focused on your
game and what your audience is
is doing uh and trying to make sure that
their experience is
is the the best it can be um we did
notice
um in years past uh if we'd go four
months without
a big content update between expansions
that um
hey sometimes the meta would settle and
there wasn't a whole lot else to explore
in the game and so people would would
begin to trickle out
uh and and hopefully come back when when
we had a new expansion
um so you know we kind of identified
that hey we need
we need more stuff happening uh and uh
and certainly we've we've kind of
rejiggered the team uh to make that
happen in the last couple of years and i
think you're seeing
seeing the results of that now dave now
now that i have you here
you're the principal narrative designer
that's your title and
i kind of just want to ask like what is
it like to incorporate
a story into a card game uh something i
learned when i
joined the hearthstone team i guess it's
almost four years ago now is sort of how
to uh
find the space to put narrative into uh
into the game in a way that uh
uh that makes sense uh and there
actually is a lot of storytelling space
um so with the year of the dragon we
linked all three expansions together
into one
overarching narrative and we're doing
something similar that you know the
three expansions in the year the phoenix
aren't linked but we do have
lots of storytelling opportunities uh
kind of with
uh with the cards themselves and uh and
then with the the solo adventure content
that comes out
uh i'll give an example um uh we're
introducing demon hunters
and so we want a villain that feels like
they are as cool as the demon hunter
class
to fight like what would be new and and
different and so we
kind of came up with this idea of the
rusted legion this sort of
half mechanized half demonic army
and uh and ideally the story then comes
into the mechanics so when you play
the ashes of outland expansion there are
cards called primes
and that is it's a a minion uh and it's
death rattle when the minion's destroyed
it's shuffled back in your deck but it's
more powerful and it emerges
as kind of a half mechanized card uh
that comes out
and you know the story behind that was
they they fell to the rusted legion and
then
they they came back so we have our main
character iran a star seeker
uh and she's gonna try and make a name
for herself by exploring outland and
quickly she's going to get in over her
head she's going to stumble on the rest
of legion
she's going to be on the run and she's
going to meet a series of other
characters
that are also on the run and these
characters are called the outcasts
and as you can imagine they use the
outcast mechanic from the ashes of
outland set
um so it's fun because you meet these
characters in the context of the set
uh when you rescue them they get
shuffled into your deck
uh and then they'll kind of continue
with you through the adventure when you
train to become a demon hunter all those
cards
also become demon hunter cards and now
you become a demon hunter
and you still have your buddies in your
deck with you and so
you kind of have the story line behind
these cards as they follow you through
the adventure
with fel fire festival there's so much
going on so if there's anything you guys
want to
uh communicate about it uh let us know
right here right now yeah i mean so
we've got so much content coming in the
fell fire festival
all of the awesome stuff that dave was
just talking about uh with the solo
adventures
like we were talking about earlier we've
got a bunch of new minions a new minion
type coming to battlegrounds
four new heroes uh and then we've got a
bunch of tavern brawls and and
much like the fell fire festival being a
twist on the fire fest
one of the different world was the burn
down which actually started as a fire
festival
tavern brawl and we've got a little
twist on the burn down this time around
too
so there's a lot of awesome stuff we
haven't talked about rewards yet i mean
it's definitely worth logging in the
hearthstone during this time like the
for the entire month
uh there's uh uh special quest rewards
uh uh to earn packs from
uh the year of the phoenix and you're
the dragon so throughout
all kinds of quests to do just jumping
in the different modes and playing the
different games
uh you're gonna earn a lot of packs so
we're pretty excited about that
all right well thank you guys so much
dave kosak connor coo
from blizzard they work on hearthstone
and they got so much rolling out so if
you
are a returning player if you haven't
played yet
this game's been out for a while get on
your phones get on your tablet get on
your pcs
yeah and i want to thank all of you for
watching for giving us your time and
attention
for game spots play for all because we
have so much great
coverage coming to you in lieu of e3
[Music]
you